baby driver's five and a half minute
opening scene skillfully introduces us
to the world of the film
sets up some of the characters and is
one of my favorite car chases
in recent cinema it does all this
without any
exposition or dialogue the scene has two
parts i'm going to talk first about what
director edgar wright sets up in the
first half of the scene
and then break down some of the
techniques he uses for the car chase in
the second half
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video
a good filmmaker will carefully use what
the audience sees and hears first
to set up the world of the film
edgar wright does this well in baby
driver before we even see anything
we hear a high-pitched tone
that fades into a musical note the
viewer won't find out until much later
in the film that baby listens to music
because of his tinnitus
but the seed of that idea is planted
firmly at the beginning of the film
in baby driver images are often
subordinate to sound a reverse of the
usual roles
so it makes sense that we hear sound
before we see images
establishing sound's critical role in
the film
the opening three shots quickly and
easily give us context for the world and
set up the main character
we see cars and a bank a sign telling us
what city we're in
and then baby's red subaru fills the
screen
calling attention to itself as the most
important piece of this scene
a sharp attentive audience that has seen
any of the marketing material for the
film
will probably be able to guess from this
one shot the scenario that's established
here
a bank robbery the second thing we see
is baby's ipod this is the first step in
establishing the fact that the music in
baby driver's soundtrack is a part of
the world
we're hearing what baby's hearing the
music isn't just something for the
audience
by making this the second shot of the
movie wright is also emphasizing the
important role that music will play in
the film
finally we see baby himself in a
close-up
our main character after baby hits play
on the ipod each of the next four cuts
happen on beat with the music
[Music]
as the crew gets out of the car the
slamming of the car doors
opening and closing of the trunk
[Music]
and their footsteps
[Music]
as well as the sounds of vehicles
beeping and passing in the streets
all synchronized with the music so in
the first seconds of the film the
audience is already introduced to the
stylistic tick
that will propel much of the film at 48
seconds into the movie the cruise masks
go on and if you hadn't managed to guess
the situation yet
it's very obvious now this is where
another important decision happens
even though the more interesting thing
the movement of the action is moving
into the bank
wright uses a wide shot and perspective
to separate baby from the crew and we
the audience
stay in the car with baby this not only
gets us comfortable with the fact that
the rest of the story will play out from
baby's perspective
it helps us separate him from the cd
criminal world baby is told later in the
film that he
isn't part of this world and it's an
idea that helps us sympathize with
baby's situation
to further establish this wright uses a
sequence of baby singing and drumming
along with the song
to juxtapose baby's attitude and
demeanor with what baby is
baby is a getaway driver but he acts
more like a bored intern
passing the time
[Music]
wright quickly reminds us however that
this separation is just an illusion
the coincidence of a passing police car
awakens baby from his reverie
and baby's view of what's happening in
the bank and the gun shot
serve as a harsh reminder for us and for
baby
of what he's involved with the audience
doesn't know it yet
but this is the central conflict for his
character
baby's concern about his relationship to
this world of crime
and it's not an accident on the
director's part that it's during this
section
that the camera is the closest to baby's
face that it's been so far
this close-up emphasizes the importance
of this moment for baby
[Music]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
right now i got to tell you about the
second part of the scene consists of a
getaway car chase
there are 164 shots spread over 3
minutes and 5 seconds
this gives us an average shot length of
1.19 seconds during the chase
other than the 23 second final tracking
shot the longest shot during the chase
is 6 seconds long
the shortest is 4 frames long 1 6 of a
second
this speed of cutting works here because
the scene functions almost
more as a musical montage of a car chase
than as a real-time depiction
of a car chase there are many apparent
jumps in time
some small and some large but this all
seems to work because of the strong role
the music plays
the chase operates first almost as a
dance choreographed to the music
and second as a depiction of vehicles
and geography
if you turn down the sound design and
watch the scene with just the music
you can see how clearly the scene is
constructed in conjunction with the
music
it doesn't just complement the scene it
drives it forward
[Music]
but the scene doesn't lose a real sense
of direction either
there are many clues that allow the
audience to follow the action
and the geography if not immediately
obvious can be picked up on
in repeat viewings but edgar wright
prioritizes showing the feeling of the
scene
over the clarity of the physical action
like in this shot
where we don't see the car swerve into
another lane
but we can almost feel its worth because
we can see the movements
and reactions of everyone in the vehicle
or
like this moment a few seconds later
where we never actually see the car make
a u-turn
but a shot of baby pulling the handbrake
and the passengers bodies shifting in
their seats as the car turns
is enough to clue us in to what happened
and it's striking
just how much time the camera spends
inside the car
59 shots are of baby or the passengers
while 78 shots are of the actual cars
while there are more shots outside the
vehicle the 60 40 split still places
much of the emphasis on what's going on
inside the vehicle this chase to me
lands closer to the effect of being in a
car chase like this
or driving a getaway car like this it's
less like the experience of merely
watching one
because of this it sacrifices some of
the clarity of geography but for good
reason
there are 52 shots of baby subaru by
itself
and 30 shots of just baby the majority
of the scene is built around that one
thing baby and his car the police the
primary conflict for the scene
even take a huge back seat only getting
incorporated into about 25 shots
often their lights appear as clear
reminders of the danger
sometimes literally encroaching on
baby's space
or more subtly in a reflection to remind
us that they're right on his tail
most of the time is spent on babies
driving and the passengers responses to
it
like this moment which takes an early
step
towards endearing us to the character
played by jon hamm
or these looks from john bernthal's
character that give us an early
indication of his skepticism towards
baby
this to me is what sets this scene apart
it's singular focus
baby and his car mirrors the singular
focus of the film
baby and his driving the interior shots
that focus on baby don't just show him
driving
they show him making decisions that
allow him to get away
we constantly see him assessing the
situation and adjusting
often in a car chase like this the lead
car just seems to be following a
predetermined path
but in this scene it's clear that they
are able to get away
because of baby's clever driving
baby's car spins and skids through
downtown atlanta
right constantly shifting the direction
of action so that things don't feel
linear
but winding and turning more like a
dance
rights directing is showcased in this
scene it's not just a big
flashy action opener to get you hooked
it does all that
but while it does it subtly feeds the
audience information
that will help them navigate the story
ahead
[Music]
thanks to squarespace for sponsoring
this video i used squarespace recently
to rebuild my website
squarespace takes so much of the pain
out of designing and running a website
that you can really focus on simply
bringing your ideas to life
it's actually kind of fun their
beautiful templates give you a great
starting place
and from there you can customize your
site easily to fit your needs
a website can be a great step in making
your idea or project a reality
so whatever it is make your next move
with squarespace
start your free trial today at
squarespace.com and enter offer code
thomasflight to get 10 off
your first purchase and check out my new
website
at thomaslight.com thank you to you for
watching this video
subscribe for more i put out a video
every month thank you so much to those
who support me on patreon and i'd like
to ask you
if you're willing to consider supporting
this channel
it would go a long way to help me cover
my cost and to be able to keep making
videos like this
i'll talk to you again next time